in Ottawa criminal trials are now
underway for two of the highest profile
leaders of last year's so-called Freedom
Convoy that shut down streets near
Parliament Hill for weeks Tamara Leach
and Chris Barber are charged with
Mischief obstructing police and
intimidation of parliament if convicted
they could be sentenced to time in jail
David Akin was in the courtroom today
David what does the prosecution have to
prove to make these charges stick well
you know Donna this is going to be a
closely watched trial for any number of
reasons not the least of which is we're
going to have two sides the crown and
the defense arguing about Free Speech
rights about the rights of protest now
in his opening statement the crown
prosecutor told the court that Charter
rights are not unqualified that they are
not absolute he promised to show how
Tamara Leach and Chris Barber were quote
key organizers of the protest that they
exercised influence over the placement
of trucks in downtown Ottawa they cause
roads to be obstructed and those two
pressured decision makers the prosecutor
told the court that quote this case is
not about their political views what's
at issue is the means Leach and barber
employed not the ends now the crown will
argue this was anything but a peaceful
process that these two crossed the lines
and they committed multiple crimes now
the defense lawyer for Barber had a very
brief reply in his in her opening
statement she said my client
participated in a lawful peaceful
protest and that the two of them
actually assisted police during the
protest Donna
David how is this trial going to play
out in terms of witnesses and testimony
well this is just day one of 16 days
that have been set aside for this
proceeding the crown expects to put out
120 exhibits including 50 videos we saw
one of those videos today a 12-minute
long compilation from the police of
video from those weeks in January and
February we're going to have 22
Witnesses police officers City officials
nine residents of downtown Ottawa and
here's something the defense will want
to exclude all those residents the
defense wants no residences residence on
the witness stand now both Tamara Leach
and Chris Barber were in court today
they were accompanied by their spouses
they didn't have much to say in the
court today and to be honest we're not
very sure if they're even going to
testify in this matter Donna all right
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you